а ось коли дженон майлз росія нарости
дізналася чума я реально у і z качу
зможуть ще до допінгу то допінгу я
системи в краї немає і ясна було чесно
змін а там ще до цього назавжди в сес
простого light все означає в ж
початок роботи над проблемою у
esp одягаюсь та й розв'язаний не поспішаючи коло
нові знання проблеми і тепер ми
побачимо ще ж ітиму
половина думаю щас вид за середовища ти
чула котлетах і дайте прозоро бешу
проблему
а сама про спортсменів порізаних вийди
у спорті на стрибок продуновий спорт та
ніж alas кравець не піку було причині
дати їй із муви
тихо системного допінгу теж ми побачила
багата санте
я думаю у продажі доступних місяців рахунки
спортсменів зимовок ти шукаєш будете в
порту мінімуму йому пару що проблеми
чума я ніби дозвону росії брата доля
узи нових олімпійських ігор 2017 раку та
на день не курей так че німці будуть за 1
душ його живим харчуванням bi rx вишок вашим
кокоболо як він надасть про те ще високо
продукті
не буду причини дуття і смоли на мою
думка цінно піф правда чоловікові його путін
низ на точно в деталях все самий
вигляд би волосся в російському спорті
червоний і мама такий же до середи ти сильно
особі Віталія каламутно
вин проти вам довгу годину кривів
російським спортом even наскільки менше
відома будуть вручати знайдуть її смоли я
бачу в цех документах вин був завчені
у систему теж на мою думку вин травня
висоту свій вигляд побачили до 5
вітебську
з США спосіб гоління затьмарить fame & shot
виїжджаємо